this is gonna sound so weird after
everything i've just said
um what's fifa ultimate basically
they you know again this is a hundred
percent like and
imagine an alien describing how humans
convert like
i've never played this myself but
obviously i'm a gamer
so i like to keep up with games yeah um
but yes essentially what it is is
microtransactions like imagine anime
like you know
because fate you can you go against each
other in fate like no p
no no so imagine a pvp fate where you
can build a team
just so happens instead of like you know
two or three characters it's like a team
of like 11
or whatever it is i think so it's
literally fifa gotcha well yeah it's
like
they're the ones who like this this is
the reason why it started like it goes
so bad like
so it's literally pay to win it's 100
pay to win and so like to even
so to be like to be able to compete
competitively
you have to have it the stacked team to
get the stack team you spend on average
like 30 000
to even have a chance of getting the
stacked team dude that's that's [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] and like you you hear
even the pros
talk about it like there's interviews
with them where they're like yeah it's
not fun at all
like you have to spend this amount of
money and everyone's playing the same
[ __ ] because everyone has the same
broken [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's so [ __ ] like you
know
we we sit here and complain about gotcha
and it's like yeah okay you know
at the end of the day it is 90 of the
time you're not
you're not playing against other people
and that's where it starts to get real
when when when you start playing against
other people that's right well that's
where i draw them
yeah because because because you're like
oh i i you know i could beat this person
or i could i could have won this event
if i just had that extra broken cap
because the way i see it is that with
gacha you with the gacha games i play
you're playing against a computer or
you're playing through to get content
um if you come if it becomes pvp then
you are
kind of making someone else's day worse
by paying more you know
definitely yeah you're making you're
making someone else's gaming experience
worse because you played more and that's
that's where i draw the line yeah
because i used to i don't know which
game i played i think i
found it on like mini clip or something
this is like when i first started
earning my own money
and there was like a game where it was
kind of like one of those like you
kind of like what's that clash of clans
like the really popular mobile game
one where you build your own fort on
your square of the map yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it takes like days
for their army to arrive
so this is like before even that was out
i was playing a game similar to that on
like mini clip or some [ __ ]
and then like i remember i was playing
this game and i thought i was doing
pretty well i i don't know and i'd only
spent like 20 bucks and i was like oh
this is i'm doing pretty good for myself
hey
and then literally like a guy who had
like the [ __ ] like just
perfect like putin's palace worth of
[ __ ] just came in and just one shot my
entire thing
that i'd spent months building just
because he clearly was like he had like
just
oil money or something this man had
everything in the game which must have
been like
50k worth of stuff and just killed me
and i was like i was like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] imagine peyton winning a
mini clip game
i was like i felt bad that i spent 20
bucks on it because i was like i was
like 18. and i was saying
a lot of money and i was like this
[ __ ]
wiped out not only the hours that i put
in but the 20 bucks that i put in were
wiped out and i couldn't [ __ ] do
anything yeah i
had to sit there and watch his army
coming for five days and then you can
drop down the men you see this man's
army
the man had sent like the equivalent of
like everything they thought and 300
against me
and i'm literally like like the [ __ ]
persian yeah i'm literally there with
like my [ __ ] like stick men
like ready and i'm seeing this army come
like four weeks ahead and i'm like
[ __ ] okay like mom get the credit card
yeah
what am i supposed to do this was so fun
oh my god and a lesser man would have
been like i can win this
unless a man would have thought i could
out i could outbid this man
so this is why people hate micro
transactions yeah i get it now i
understand gamers that's i think from
that moment on
as i slowly saw that men's army
approached me
the resentment built every day to the
point where i was like i can't
this is [ __ ] i'm just watching my work
be destroyed
so what i i guess going back to the fifa
ultimate thing i'm curious like
how do people even become pros does that
mean you have like
you did legit be good i mean you know
literally
you have to be good and also have
disposable income yeah to become a pro
and fifa
yeah then i guess isn't it sad that when
you're going to a tournament there's
probably some people at that tournament
who are like
need that money to recruit the money
they put in just to like isn't that sad
oh that is that that is [ __ ] like okay
you know
you know normally you know if you're if
you're an amazing fighting game player
all you got to worry about is the
the hotel getting there and you know
making sure you have enough to live
which is all okay which is difficult
enough yeah
but you add on that of like oh so i
spent 50k on peach
like to to enter this map you know what
i mean it's like this is ridiculous
like it's so [ __ ] i feel bad for the
like the people playing fifa who like
genuinely like the game we have to deal
with the [ __ ] yeah
i didn't i didn't know he had a
competitive scene at all because i mean
i stopped playing after
after like oh nine ten and i'm just like
okay that that that is behind me i
literally blanked it from my memory so
you got out
um